hey monkey yeah do you know where we're
at right now
yes we're in the city well we live in
Summerlin and every weekend I have
something cool I'm not in the desert
with Las Vegas yep but the city is
called Summerlin so in downtown
Summerlin every weekend they have
something cool going on this weekend
they have a farmer's market do you know
what that is
awesome I'm gonna show you what that is
and they have this thing called Touch a
Truck do you know what that is
awesome two really cool things I want to
show you you ready
you ready no okay yes no yes no yes no
yes
so what's the first thing you want to
look at dude
in the excavator look at that there's so
much stuff here holy moly okay let's go
so we haven't even done anything yet but
look at the lines to see anything we're
on this line to get on the little
excavator because that's what taiku
wants to do right you want to get on the
little excavator
[Applause]
the big one sorry sorry
and it's freaking nuts huh
oh yeah there's a long line everywhere
this is
nuts
all right taika you're next in line what
are you thinking right now what are you
gonna do what's the strategy here I
can't hear you you're gonna honk the
horn yep we're gonna go what else you're
gonna do what else what else what else
are you thinking you're gonna drive it
okay all right anything anything else
anything else dude
oh my God okay
okay we'll see when you get on
go dude
push it
there's another button right there by
your thumb
okay too much too much
that's it that's it oh my God everyone
there
are you destroying dude
[Applause]
taika how was that
[Music]
well you got on
I'm not fun not fun why no because I
wanted to go okay well we're going to
the excavator now okay
up there
I don't know if that's part of it
I don't think it's part of this but we
can go check okay
well it's like a it's a it's a machine
and it goes up kind of like an elevator
but it goes straight up
so taika you're about to finally get on
the excavator of your dreams turn around
dude I'm talking to you are you excited
is this what you came here for yeah
after this do you want to go home no
just kidding okay what are you gonna do
us the first thing you do when you get
it
it does what are you gonna do when you
get in
of course okay you ready dude yeah okay
how can we get
it's your turn dude
Hey listen to the gentleman okay here we
go go dude
[Applause]
nice
he's been just waiting to do that
just taking it all in dude
okay well that was a lot that's oh
that's a lot
[Applause]
okay oh geez that's it there's cotton
candy there's pina colada
that one's cotton candy
okay bubble gum watermelon and raspberry
watermelon
that's it
holy moly okay
this way come on
[Applause]
what's this can I tell you something
can I tell you something
I think this is my favorite part so far
we're in the shade
out of this beautiful tree it's quiet
there's no line and you're eating
something yummy you did a good job okay
tell me something your turn
yeah
and I didn't share you're so mean
got it oh Tykes where are we going now
to the bus
come on
[Applause]
let's go back
whoa whoa I got their shoulders your
hips like that your hips your hips
close
hips hips
let's go dude
so why did you want to come in the
ambulance
did you know that you've been in an
ambulance before
you did but you still want to come in it
do not write anything
[Applause]
I swear this is
trash okay but we've never been in the
front that's a new one
[Applause]
yeah leave it leave it I think it's for
one of the workers just leave it
[Music]
I'm gonna drive
don't touch anything don't touch
anything
okay no more hunky no more honking
oh my God
this kid
go
[Music]
oh no I gotta send this to your pop
[Applause]
whoa not very comfy
watch your feet okay
[Music]
wow dude super cool
I just want to honk everything huh let
me win okay ready go
[Music]
I'm such a bad vlogger taika and I have
left thank God that was nuts
um but now we're having lunch together
and psycho wanted to sit next to me what
did you order dude
spaghetti and meatball
how do you like it
[Applause]
thumbs up it's pretty good and I got a
carbonara
Lobster carbonara which I've never had
but it's bomb that's Joker noodles so
our noodles yeah it's pasta
nantaga eat the bread and you tried the
what is that called again the black
thing the sauce balsamic vinegar
yeah did you like it
oh it was Sour okay
and the cutest thing he just asked me so
he's making small talk and he was like
huh that's your job and I had to like
ask him again because I was like what
he's never asked me how my job was and
we started talking about my job what
does mama and papa do do you remember
what I said he makes sure
yeah we make sure it's good yeah yeah
it's okay it's a hard word to say
okay Mia now it's your turn so we were
away for I think a few hours
any reports on the house while we were
gone anything you want to add
you thinking about it nothing hey
with what oh it's tucked okay
Mia no reports okay she doesn't want to
talk so what was that
oh I see so tyke and I came back home
after lunch and what did we do
[Laughter]
it's not true we didn't dance
does your long hair feel good on your
back
Tech is letting his hair grow by the way
you don't want to cut your hair anytime
soon no no does it feel good
hey what did we do when we got back we
did okay we didn't dance we actually
took a nap I did I took a nap in the
living room
and then I promised that we were gonna
do what Mia's just like I'm used to this
[Music]
no you didn't you probably pooped in
your pants no
no
monkey
how do we feel right now are you happy
are you sad
she'd like somewhere for ice cream yeah
how could you yeah how could you look
how could you lick his ice cream
hey
well that's yours yeah I brought to take
it to one of my food I uh parked so when
we first moved here we lived right
over there
we lived right over there but look at
how beautiful this park next to the
community
is everyone comes out and people study
and dogs and kids run and it's just a
grand old time and this mofo just no no
no left his ice cream yo Tykes come
[Music]
action
oh my God
are you dead or alive oh heart I get out
thank you I really do love this park
what type is doing with the rest of the
neighborhood kids
they just bring
they bring okay Mia they bring cardboard
boxes and they just slide down this hill
look at that
so fun
get him get him get him get
[Applause]
not me yeah
not media
how
run run and see if she chases you
[Music]
yeah she wants all the smoke
okay
no no no
always getting weapons
she's gonna get you
no why weapons leave it no
she's nervous she's nervous
big dum dum
hey how do you say butt butt in Spanish
how do you say it
foreign
[Music]
no you don't say that
get your little pumpies
she's gonna bite you
she's gonna bite your little stinky
steam buns
ow I don't want to play
oh that's so mean say sorry
no not like that
okay time to take a shower
don't put that on your head please
you're gonna suffocate dude
okay on that note thank you guys so much
for watching I'm exhausted from that
hard thingy I don't recommend it at all
or if you do go go like the last hour or
two that's when it was a chillest
that was intense I think I need like a
whole day to recover from that anyway no
no buenas noches no
no